all right guys this is going to be a
very interesting video you know when
Noah and his family stepped off the ark
what was the world like just imagine
what was the world like for them and for
the generations after them how did they
survive in this new world and start
civilizations and why did it becomes so
evil at the Tower of Babel
and then what about the animals did they
really come from the ark
and what about the dinosaurs or dragons
because we know that the word dinosaur
did not exist back then
well let's get into this interesting and
amazing video let's go back into the
past
[Music]
thank you
foreign
now in the previous video we talked
about how brutal and evil the world was
in the time before the flood in the
anti-diluvian period when the Fallen
Angels Came Down
when the Nephilim started to walk the
earth
and men who only thought evil
continually
until God had to step in and stop it all
with the flood
but then we see the same thing happening
again after the flood people became more
and more evil
at the Tower of Babel especially why
did some of the ancient knowledge
somehow survived the flood teaching
people to worship other gods AKA fallen
angels
and how to use evil crops and so forth
because we do know that the people After
the flood had some sort of ancient
knowledge secret Sciences they even knew
how to practice Magic
some ancient writings call it the seven
sacred Sciences which people perverted
and used for evil
some of this knowledge which is about
basic things like building buildings
masonry we know the Babylonians acadians
and Assyrians and other nations
continued to build amazing buildings
like ziggurats and might even have
repaired some of the pre-flood
cigarettes and kept these Legends or
cultures alive
now for those of you who know about the
Freemasons it is interesting that the
Freemasons believe that the ancient
corrupted Sciences the the knowledge
first moved from Babylon and Syria to
Egypt and I mentioned two possible ways
of how that could have happened but I
don't have time to delve into that
completely now it is interesting though
that the Bible does talk about corrupted
Sciences or knowledge it doesn't call it
by its name but we see that there were
certain people who practiced strange
things like magic do you remember the
evil Sorceress in Egypt Exodus 7 verse
11 then Pharaoh also called for the wise
men and sorceress
now why were these men called wise they
knew certain things
and also the Sorceress and they along
with the Egyptian magicians did the same
thing with their secret Arts
so the Bible does mention secret Arts
verse 12 so each one threw down his
stuff and it became a serpent but
Aaron's stuff swallowed up their Stars
now in the past people who rebelled
against God used knowledge secret
knowledge for evil people also used
knowledge for good but these people use
the knowledge they perverted it
especially in a time when the Fallen
Angels Came To Earth and we know that a
lot of people followed demons teachings
of demons and so they've gained these
secret arts or the knowledge of these
secret Arts to do evil many ancient
writings actually say that the Fallen
Angels when they came down to sleep with
the woman of Earth to create the
Nephilim that they also gave secret
knowledge craft Arts two people to teach
them so that they can be lured away and
not obey God but that they now serve
these demons as gods and we even see it
after the flood how astronomy was
perverted to astrology and was
associated with magicians sorceress
Chaldeans or the Magi even in the time
of Jesus these kind of people were
around these wise men these Magi because
of the star they knew about Jesus
Matthew 2 now when Jesus was born in
Bethlehem of Judea in the days of Herod
the King Herod the Great Magi wise men
from the East came to Jerusalem asking
where is he who has been born King of
the Jews for we have seen his star in
the east and have come to worship Him so
is this part of the reason why the Earth
became so evil again after the flood
shortly after the flood at the Tower of
Babel because of this secret perverted
ancient knowledge and if it is part of
the reason where did they get the
knowledge from that some of this ancient
knowledge somehow survived the flood on
stone tablets
that one of Noah's children or
children's children pervert the good
knowledge of Noah which he received from
his family line all the way from Adam
who of course spent time with God
himself in the garden
or what happened
and after the flood think about all the
other things as well what was the world
really like the animals that all the
animals greatly repopulate the Earth
what about the dinosaurs or called
dragons before 1841. so many questions
all right so let's start at the
beginning first let's focus on Noah
Before the Flood he was the 10th
Generation from Adam according to
Genesis 5 Adam had Seth who had enosh
then came Keenan mahalal Jared Enoch
Methuselah lamech and then Noah
10 generations and there was something
special about Noah that you might not
know God had a plan for Noah even his
name Noah meant something special
Genesis 5 verse 28 when lehmig had lived
182 years he fathered a son and called
his name Noah saying out of the ground
that the Lord has cursed this one shall
bring us relief from our work and from
the painful toil of our hands so lamec
had knowledge about Noah that we don't
because of his name and because of what
he said his name means that he will
bring relief for them now Noah might
have also looked different that might
have been part of the reason why lameck
said this or called him Noah I'm not 100
sure here but one of the apocryva books
does describe Noah which is very
interesting The Book of Enoch says this
about his description the Flesh of which
was white as snow and red as a rose the
hair of whose head was white like wool
and long and whose eyes were beautiful
when he opened them he illuminated all
the house like the sun
interesting isn't it but please know and
understand every time when I quote from
something that is not part of the Bible
like the upper criva and what other
ancient writers said it is interesting
what they said and it could have been
true but we're not 100 sure you can
however trust the Bible which has been
inspired by God and is the only absolute
truth we have to Timothy 3 16 says all
scripture is breathed out by God and
profitable for teaching for reproof for
correction and for training in
righteousness that the man of God may be
complete equipped for every good work
now you know the meaning of Noah but did
you know that if you take the names of
Adam Seth and the whole line until Noah
each of them
their names mean something and if you
put it together it makes a sentence and
that sentence is a prophecy about the
Messiah Jesus Christ take a look at this
Adam means man Seth means appointed
enosh mortal Keenan sorrow Mahala the
blessed one Jared shall come down
Enoch teaching
Methuselah his death shall bring
lamech the despairing
Noah rest or comfort
Now read it with me all together the man
appointed mortal sorrow this shows the
fall of humankind of man that sin
entered the world
the blessed one shall come down teaching
this is Jesus coming down to teach us
the truth his death shall bring the
despairing rest and comfort
and that's exactly what Jesus came to do
to come and make us free so that we can
enter his eternal rest
you see before Jesus came people try to
obey the law just from their own will
right their own soul they couldn't Time
After Time After Time
sin just took over because of the sinful
nature that is within us but then Jesus
came to die for our sin on the cross
and now those who look to him who
believe in Jesus Christ as Lord and
Savior will be saved so now God the
father when he judges us he looks
through Jesus what he did for us on the
cross and he declares us as righteous
but not only that
if we accept him he comes to live inside
of us he makes us a new creation we
become spiritually alive
and we have now the ability to have a
relationship with God again the same way
that Adam had before sin came into the
world we still have that fleshly nature
but now we also have the new spiritual
nature in us and the Bible says that we
can only worship God in spirit and in
truth because God is spirit all right
let's go back to Noah in Genesis chapter
7 God gave Noah specific instructions to
build an ark and this is what happened
verse 11 in the 600th year of Noah's
life in a second month on the 17th day
of the month on that day all The
Fountains of the great deep burst forth
and the windows of the heavens were open
so the water did not just come from the
heavens from the clouds it burst through
the Earth
and it's it's very interesting that
recently they discovered a huge ocean
near the Earth's core and Stephen
Jacobson from Northwestern University in
Evanston Illinois says it's good
evidence the Earth's water Came From
Within
is right the post-flood world the world
that we live in now has a lot more water
on the surface compared to the
anti-diluvian world verse 13 says on the
very same day Noah and his sons Shem and
ham and yepeth and Noah's wife and the
three wives of his sons with them
entered the Ark
they and every Beast according to its
kind
I'll tell you in a few minutes why this
is important according to its kind and
all the livestock according to their
kinds and every creeping thing that
creeps on the Earth according to its
kind and every bird according to its
kind and every winged creature
so all the animals that lived before the
flood in the antediluvian period they
didn't all just go on the ark the Bible
says two of every kind
and he says that four times in verse 14
for a reason so that we can hear
and understand
so
after hundreds of years you will have
different types but it's the same kind
for example
we get different types of horses today
but they are still horses not something
else
we also get many types of dogs but they
are still dogs not cats or Mouse
so was it possible to fit them all on
the ark all the different kinds of
animals and beasts two of every kind
what about the dinosaurs or back then
called the dragons
well I answered the same question on my
other channel so check it out
so every animal of its kind
that includes dinosaurs I might say
Daniel that's just that's just crazy
dinosaurs are huge so there's no way
that huge dinosaurs could have been
brought on the ark with all of the other
animals as well that might be true not
huge dinosaurs and huge animals but
babies definitely
it will be much easier and wiser to take
small animals into the ark and not big
and old ones so that after the flood
they could have lived longer and produce
more babies big dinosaurs were big well
some of them depending on their kind
right but the babies were well babies
small
do you know what the biggest egg fossil
is that they found of dinosaurs the
biggest dinosaur egg fossil was around
the size of a football
that's it that's close to an ostrich egg
so imagine the size of dinosaur that
could come out of that egg not very big
right and then before the flood they had
hundreds of years to grow right remember
lizards they never stop growing and so
they have hundreds of years to grow
because that's how all the people got at
that time as well very very old some
over 900 years old and the Ark was a lot
bigger than people think
[Music]
the ark encounter in Northern Kentucky
shows us they created the ark replica
according to the instructions of the
Bible and so doing proved that it was
possible to bring so many different
animals on the ark take some time and go
visit them when you have the chance
all right now if you want to watch the
rest of that video and also part two
where I explain how the dinosaurs became
extinct dragons then you can hop on to
my other channel after this video I'll
add it to your new video description so
you can check it out now how was it
possible for the humans to repopulate
again Noah and his family were not
cavemen dumb and looked like apes
they were intelligent humans who did not
start over from scratch not knowing how
to build houses
I mean they learned how to build the ark
put yourself in their shoes you would
have prepared for this new world
so I believe that Noah and his family
prepared they brought all the Knowledge
and Skills the things that they needed
with them on the ark including the
memories knowing where people from the
pre-flood world the anti-deluvian world
lived
so over time they could have checked out
these places to see what is left after
the flood
and even repaired some of it if it was
possible and God didn't just leave them
and say all right go and try to
repopulate the Earth he actually blessed
them
to repopulate the Earth Genesis 9 and
God blessed Noah and his sons and said
to them
be fruitful and multiply and fill the
Earth
so they did but sadly the world became
evil again
why
well Noah had only three sons he had
Shem ham and yape
now Abraham and the nation of Israel
came from Shem and I believe most of the
evil people came from the line of ham
these children were Kush Egypt foot and
Canaan according to Genesis 10.
now I know this video is long but this
is important so please Focus listen up
so ham had Kush and Kush had
Nimrod you would remember Nimrod from my
previous videos he was the first world
leader in a sense who built many cities
and something else as well which is very
interesting
the Tower of Babel was built through him
and it was built in Rebellion against
God verse 8 Kush fathered Nimrod he was
the first on the earth to be a Mighty
Man
he was a mighty Hunter before the Lord
therefore it is said like Nimrod a
mighty Hunter before the Lord
the beginning of his kingdom was Babel
Iraq akkad and kalne in the land of
shinar
in a sense this almost feels like a
fantasy story like the lord of rings
because it talks about the land of
shinar there's a lot of ideas that
Hollywood takes from the Bible if you
just focus
verse 11 says from that land he went
into Assyria and built Nineveh
kala and resin between Nineveh and kala
that is the great City
now this is where it gets very
interesting
and the Bible doesn't give us a lot of
information of why it got so evil again
it gave us just a bit of information so
that we can understand how people spread
throughout the world and how Abraham
came into the world how his son started
the nation of Israel and how the Messiah
of Prophecy came because that's what the
Bible is all about about Jesus the Old
Testament and the new
now I believe it got so evil because
human beings are evil we have a sinful
nature within us and if we don't want to
worship God the light then we move into
darkness and as Generations go on it
becomes more evil but it became
in a sense it was accelerated they were
put on The Fast Track because of the
devil and his demons
who gave them the same ancient corrupted
knowledge that they made available
through the fallen angels to humans
Before the Flood there is a spiritual
world that we cannot see
and the devil and his demons they've
always influenced human beings but it
will become more clear to you as we
continue in this video
let's read Genesis 11 verse 1. now the
whole earth had one language and the
same words and as people migrated from
the East they found a plane in the land
of shinar and settled there now you
remember in the previous verse it said
that the land of shinar is the kingdom
that Nimrod started like Babel verse 3
and they said to one another come let us
make bricks and burn them thoroughly
and they had brick for stone and buteman
for Mortar
this shows us again that they were
Advanced civilizations having the
knowledge to build amazing buildings
verse 4 then they said come let us build
ourselves a city and a tower with its
top in the heavens and let us make a
name for ourselves lest we be dispersed
over the face of the whole Earth
lest we be dispersed over the face of
the whole Earth
remember
the flood came so that was the Judgment
of God now again they don't want to be
judged by God if they continue in their
own ways in their sin so they want to
build a place for themselves reaching to
the heavens
and build this Tower in Rebellion
against God I'll explain this a little
bit further on now the Bible doesn't
talk about the ancient knowledge that
they had apart from what they built
right the the effects of of the
knowledge so they had to have the
knowledge to be able to build these
amazing cities and also the Tower of
Babel so we know that they have they had
masonry skills but other ancient
writings
explain a little bit more some call it
the seven sacred Sciences which include
geometry and astronomy
According to some there was a pure
branch of knowledge and an evil branch
of knowledge
there was always this fight between good
and evil and even if we go back before
the flood back back back back back to
the Garden of Eden there was the tree of
Good and Evil Genesis 2 verse 17 but of
the tree of the knowledge of Good and
Evil you shall not eat for in the day
that you eat of it you shall surely die
and then you know the rest of the story
The Devil said You shall not surely die
if you eat of it you will be like God
knowing good from evil and what did they
do they listened to the devil why maybe
because they wanted to be like God
so they took the fruit they ate it and
they did die as God said they died
spiritually
because they couldn't have a
relationship with God anymore because
sin entered them now they had knowledge
of evil
and God is Holy he cannot have a
relationship with you if you live in
darkness if you are evil so they died
spiritually and we know John 4 24 says
God is spirit and you can only worship
Him in spirit and Truth
so they died spiritually and they
brought it on all humankind who were
born from them
they knew now
the knowledge of good and also the
knowledge of evil and according to some
the seven sacred Sciences are also
connected to the secret society of
Freemasons we have today and the
Illuminati those who rebelled against
God used the knowledge for evil and also
with the Fallen Angels who gave them
certain information they used all of
that for evil which includes mysticism
and secret rituals according to the book
The Spirit of Freemasonry Freemasonry
was not based on just normal
architecture but rather on religious and
moral tenets
I believe that those people who rebelled
against God After the flood did so in
exactly the same way that the people did
Before the Flood using the same
knowledge to start evil religions and
occultic practices worshiping Fallen
Angels demons and Nephilim as God
with this game sorcery mysticism evil
rituals and so much more
and that is probably why this happened
in verse 5 and the Lord came down to see
the city and the tower which the
children of man had built and the Lord
said behold they are one people and they
have all one language and this is only
the beginning of what they will do
so God saw where this was leading them
towards an evil World exactly the same
as the pre-flood world
so he came down to stop it yet again
because of their prideful Hearts now
building the tower because they wanted
to rebel against God they want to ascend
into heaven following the false
teachings of Fallen Angels doing these
ancient
perverted crops evil rituals mysticism
starting these religions of these Fallen
Angels pretending to be Gods the
Nelson's Bible dictionary says the tower
was created as a symbol for human pride
and Rebellion
I believe they could have built this
Tower in Rebellion against God against
the heavens
to follow now again this pantheistic
religion of the Nephilim and the Fallen
Angels now of course a lot of this has
to do with Nimrod who many say that the
the Epic of Gilgamesh you know from
Babylon the Babylonian Epic of Gilgamesh
if you don't know about it search it
many say that this is actually about
nimrod Gary Wayne says in his book The
Genesis 6 conspiracy all this took place
at a time when a dictator Nimrod had
usurped absolute control by force
establishing the first Empire of the new
Epoch with Babel as its first United
project Nimrod ignited a conspiracy
modeled after the Genesis 6 conspiracy
which had constructed the Egyptian
pyramids and the Sumerian ziggurats as
memorials and a legacy to their spurious
anti-deluvian accomplishments
now this is actually a great book to
read and I won't say that I agree with
everything in it
as I said before
I trust the Bible 100 everything else
you have to read with goggles Through
the Bible
don't just trust everything you read but
also don't throw the baby away with the
bath water this is very important now I
think that the idea of nimrod it could
have been that he wanted to unite the
whole world under one world government
where he is the leader using one
religion
of course also all the information given
to him by Satan himself
and he's fallen angels given to him by
someone called Hermes
and I believe all of this happened for
one reason and that is to rebel against
God to lead people away from him
as the devil has always tried to do with
World governments and certain people who
want to control the world
it is also interesting that the
Freemasons call Nimrod the first Grand
Master After the flood you see God knew
that the world was sliding
into evil again Rebellion violence
sexual sin and debauchery all under the
disguise of a promised new world
does this not sound familiar to the
world that we live in now
if you just open your eyes and see
what's going on
it's the same thing repeating itself
Before the Flood After the flood if you
look in history and until this period we
are now closer than ever there are still
secret societies and I won't go in
detail here because then it will take my
video off of YouTube
but there are secret societies who still
want one world one religion one
government where they control what you
think and believe and how you live
when Nimrod did this and God saw where
this was heading with the Tower of Babel
he stopped it verse 6 and the Lord said
behold they are one people and they have
all one language and this is only the
beginning of what they will do and
nothing that they propose to do
will now be impossible for them
I believe that this is talking about all
the evil Acts
I mean with the new movie that just came
out the sound of Freedom it opened
people's eyes to just the trafficking
that's going on around them
millions of people it's 150 billion
dollar industry that's just part of the
evil that's going on in the world there
is a lot more
that is part of the reason why God
stopped it even back then
to stop all the evil verse 7 come let us
go down and there confuse their language
so that they may not understand one
another's speech
so the law dispersed them from there
over the face of all the Earth and they
left off building the city therefore its
name was called Babel because there the
Lord confused the language of all the
Earth and from there the Lord dispersed
them over the face of all the Earth
now Josephus the Jewish historian he
wrote something interesting he said that
they built a tower so that they can find
shelter in case God wanted to flood the
world again
which we of course know you wouldn't
have done he still won't do it today
because that is his promise you still
see it today the rainbow
the rainbow is the sign that he won't
flood the Earth again and today a
rainbow is even used for something else
the lgbtq community
actually the original design they used
had eight colors the one they use now
it's got only six colors but God's
rainbow has seven colors so you can
fully enjoy it when you see it in nature
after the rain
now according to Josephus the second
reason why they built the Tower of Babel
was so that nimrod
could have sent into heaven and kill God
as crazy as it seems that's one of the
reasons so that he can avenge himself
and the people and the people of the
pre-flood world he wanted to slay The
God Who had caused the great flood of
Noah's time just in case God decided to
judge the Earth again with another flood
you know you will hear different stories
about that time from different cultures
by the time of the flood and also after
it
it might have different names but it's
the same people and you will start to
see a Common Thread of Truth through all
the stories because it is the same
people and the same things that happen
even the Hebrew Legends tell how Nimrod
even staged events where he shot arrows
into heaven in an attempt to slay God an
Aztec Legend
a famous cigarette was built by Giants
to transform men into gods and another
Legend said the ziggurat built by giant
men resulted in the dispersal of
humankind remember there were Nephilim
at this time as I explained in the
previous video
and this ziggurat sounds like the Tower
of Babel now Adam and Eve could have
gained a lot of Knowledge from God in
the time they walked with him in the
garden knowledge God gave them about
himself humans and the world which they
probably shared with their children
but humans could have perverted this
knowledge if they rebel against God if
they follow their own sinful flesh now
and
use this knowledge for evil there's just
a lot of things that can go worse
especially with the Fallen Angels or
demons giving them more information to
pervert this knowledge even further and
this is nothing new and it will continue
to happen people will follow the
teachings of demons 1 Timothy 4 verse 1
now the spirit expressly says that in
later times some will depart from the
Faith by devoting themselves to
deceitful spirits and teachings of
demons
but now let's go deeper let's go back
some say that Adam told this to his
children his line of children especially
also the the line of Seth to Noah and
Noah After the flood taught it to his
children they say the evil knowledge
spread from Cain to his descendants like
lamech the evil remember the Bible says
Before the Flood that people only
thought evil continually they followed
evil they did Evil it was a time where
the Nephilim were there the Fallen
Angels it was just
uh a soup of evil practicing occultic
rituals committing murder raping
stealing sexual sins and the list just
goes on
now this Super Evil time probably
happened in the time right after the
Fallen Angels Came To Earth and created
the half breach the Nephilim because
right in the next verse it says this
verse 5 the Lord saw that the wickedness
of man was great in the earth and that
every intention of the thoughts of his
heart was only evil continually
some of these sources say that the
evilemik from caneside wrote all this
ancient perverted Sciences on two
pillars so that the people After the
flood could still get this information
and that it could guide them
the one pillar was made of latrous some
type of brick so it won't sink and the
other made of marble so that it won't
burn
supposedly the first pillar the one made
out of Latrice had the seven sacred
corrupted Sciences inscribed on it the
second pillar of marble contained the
directions to the location of the nine
vaults of Enoch some say that it was
buried at the foot of the pyramids
you know they have a lot of interesting
documentaries on the pyramids and they
will tell you what they want you to know
they'll make it interesting so that you
would wander as well but they will never
really tell you the truth
but that's a video for another time
according to the craft Legends
Freemasons the history of the sciences
and their doctrines along with the
Arcane rituals were preserved by the
children of lamech on a brass pillar in
hieroglyphics
so again some say that the pure sacred
knowledge came from Adam
uh Seth and then up to Noah and his
children others say that the the
corrupted evil sacred sciences came from
Cain and then to lameck the evil amec
and his children and that's where all
the evil sin came from before the world
and spread until God washed it all away
with the flood now the Bible doesn't
mention this but the Bible does mention
something very interesting about the
evil lamex children who had interesting
knowledge it mentions their names and
also what they were able to do but why
why only lemak's children
I mean even if you look at Adam's side
it does not mention any detail of Adam
and Eve's other children but only the
line of the third child Seth where Noah
came from now as you remember in the
beginning of the video I read you two to
three verse 16 that says that the word
of God was inspired by God right written
by humans but through the power of the
holy spirit so it is perfect you can
trust it
and everything in it is true and
important
so it is important it was important for
God to include the evil laymac the names
of his children and what they could do
Genesis 4 verse 19 and lamech took two
wives the name of the one was Ada and
the name of the other Zilla Ada bore
jabal he was the father of those who
dwell in tents and have livestock his
brother's name was Juba he was the
father of all those who played the liar
and pipe now remember even with music
you can use music for evil even in
rituals or he can use it for good verse
22 Zilla also bore tubal Kane he was the
forger of all instruments of bronze and
iron
there's a lot of instruments that you
can make with bronze and iron the sister
of tubal Kane was nama now let me just
remind you other writings say that this
is where the Fallen Angels Came Down
with these family lineages
especially in the time of laymeck and
his children and created the Nephilim
and taught them these
perverted Sciences so that they could
use it for evil and bring evil over over
the whole world and according to them
this is where evil started to spread
around the world in the pre-flood world
and where the pantheistic religion
started to worship fallen angels
pretending to be gods and this can be
true it could have been in this time
because even in the time of Seth they
still worship God many many of the
children of Adam and Eve still worship
God the Bible says this other sources
say this and even the Freemasons
according to Dr Oliver who wrote the
book called Antiquities of Freemasonry
describe Seth as one who Associated only
with the most virtuous people of his age
who were celebrated as the sons of Light
huh so a group of people the tribe Seth
his people his children who were called
the Sons of light
sounds interesting the Bible also says
in Genesis 4
to Seth also a son was born and he
called his name enosh at that time
people began to call upon the name of
the Lord
enosh and they still worship God but
even later at Enoch's time they still
worship God this is the good Enoch not
the evil one from the the line of Cain
it might be a bit confusing here and
there because there are two names in the
lineages of Seth and of Cain that are
similar
the names Enoch and lameck now Adam had
Seth he had enosh who had Keenan then
mahalal then Jared and then Enoch the
Seventh Generation who still worshiped
God and the flood came at the 10th
Generation
so at the Seventh Generation they
worshiped God at the 10th Generation
there was the flood so they suddenly
became evil the whole world
apart from Noah
do you understand this just in those few
Generations now
how did this happen
while the Bible doesn't say this so I
can't say that this is 100 for sure but
other ancient writings do like Josephus
and the Apocrypha books that became evil
because of the Fallen Angels also called
Watchers with the leader called Azazel
and their mixed breed Offspring who
people started to worship as God
especially the humans from the line of
Cain
so everything I'm telling you now comes
from all these other ancient writings
and they say that these Fallen Angels
taught humans the evil sacred Sciences
corrupting the good sciences and also
teaching them just other evil things
like the seventh science astronomy which
led to astrology and was used for evil
now just very quick if you think
astrology is not evil if you believe in
your star sign and that your future is
determined by certain stars or what
month you're born please watch my video
on this I'll link it very in the video
description just so you can have an idea
of why this is evil so let me just back
up a little bit so there was a pure
branch of good knowledge and then an
evil one a perverted one with the help
of the Fallen Angels Adam learned things
directly from God In the Garden of Eden
then he had Cain and Abel which he
probably taught many things for example
both of them knew how to farm Kane with
plants and able with animals but Kane
killed Abel and went East with all his
knowledge and he started cities being a
Mason having not only knowledge in
farming but also architecture
so after Kane Adam and Eve had Seth and
then many other Sons and Daughters the
Bible doesn't say exactly how many I'll
tell you what Josephus says in just a
second
but they probably taught all that they
knew
part of that some of these interesting
sciences that and other things that they
learned from God and they probably
taught them to use it for good
now Joseph is the Jewish historian wrote
that Adam and Eve had 33 sons and 23
daughters now again the Bible doesn't
say how many kids they have but this
could have been true so
let's just focus on Seth now and uh Kang
so Kane went to East with all the
knowledge he and his descendants used it
for evil
Seth he lived righteously and used the
knowledge for good according to the
upper kriva books Josephus and other
writings Kane's descendants used all the
knowledge perverted it with the help of
the Fallen Angels and they they did
rituals and a lot of evil things until
it was so bad that God had to stop it
but before the flood came they
supposedly wrote their seven sacred
Sciences that's perverted
on pillars and hieroglyphics so that the
people After the flood can continue
these evil Deeds that came from the
Fallen Angels
After the flood the devil was still
there and demons as they still are today
so they started to go to work working on
people's fleshly sinful Natures to get
them to turn from God again and to
follow the perverted knowledge and
worship false gods alright now I'm gonna
go deeper now it's gonna get interesting
so wake up refresh
refocus here we go now most of this come
from other ancient writing so I'm not
sure how much of this is true but a lot
of it could be true
After the flood a man called Hermes will
also later be called Toth the new
Egyptian god of wisdom went with him
Noah's son to Egypt and found it the
ancient perverted knowledge Hermes
decoded the hieroglyphics and gave the
information to Nimrod which is why Egypt
built their empire so quickly
especially with the knowledge of how to
use hieroglyphics
and this is why Nimrod was also so
powerful
now some writers say that Abraham told
the Egyptians astrology
Josephus also says that Abraham taught
them
the signs of arithmetic and astronomy
and another writer called efolomus
actually says Abraham invented astrology
before he went to Egypt
which I of course don't believe even
Philo claimed Abraham studied astronomy
and Mathematics
could they be right well
I'm not sure Abraham probably was well
educated because of his family line so
there's a lot of things that he could
have known remember Abraham came from
Shem and Shem had our fax ad and Abraham
came only 292 years after our factset so
Shem was still alive because he lived
400 years after the flood so he could
have learned a lot of things from his
family line even from Shem Abraham or
Abram as he was called back then before
God called him
I mean he was an important he was a very
important figure especially today for
Christians Muslims and Jews but a lot of
people forget that he did not worship
God in the beginning Joshua 24 2 and
Joshua said to all the people thus says
the Lord the god of Israel long ago your
fathers lived beyond the Euphrates
Terror the father of Abraham and avnahor
and they served other gods
yeah they served other gods Abraham used
to live in the ancient city of UR of the
galdeans
which was in modern Iraq the great
cigarette of UR was built by Ur namu
around 2100 before Christ and was
dedicated to Nana the moon God
remember this was the same pantheistic
religion of worshiping the demons I
talked about the moon goddess in the
previous video is the same pantheistic
religion where they worship fallen
angels
they did that before the flood now
remember in Genesis 12 Abraham was
around 75 years old
when God called him go from your country
and your Kindred and your father's house
to the land that I will show you and I
will make you a great nation and I will
bless you and make your name great so
that you will be a blessing now it is
likely that Abraham could have had
knowledge of Yahweh passed down from
family to to family but a lot of them
started to worship other gods the moon
goddess and the other gods we talked
about in the previous videos but then
something amazing happened
Yahweh God called Abraham directly
and then he followed God Abraham
actually called him the most high God
Genesis 14 22 but Abram said to the king
of Sodom I have lifted my hand to the
Lord God most high possessor of Heaven
and Earth
so Abram and his family started to
follow God Yahweh but remember most of
the other nations still follow these
other fake Gods which is part of the
perverted sacred knowledge or ancient
knowledge according to Gary Wayne from
Egypt the new religious cloak draped
over the corrupted Sciences was
transferred to the Greeks and Romans and
to many other Pagan nations of the
Mediterranean most of the religious
beliefs spread through Nimrod and Hermes
who became a priest and to some even a
God now remember a few minutes ago I
told you that Hermes will also be called
Toth the Egyptian God is the same thing
just different names with different
cultures as time went on Hermes is also
the name of the Greek god of
interpretive communication they started
the old religion that was there before
the flood again after the flood with
Osiris and Isis used as the model for
the other Pagan Nations
Osiris was the best known the Greeks
called him Bacchus the Martians of Asia
Minor called him panuses or Apollo the
Indians named him Dionysus the Romans
called him libber and the Arabians
Adonis it was the same Mystic religions
found in the same Sun God allegories now
let me get to the point here we know
that God is the only God he is the True
Light
the devil is not a god at all he's just
a fallen angel and the weaker Angels
below him they're just Angels they're
not gods they have power but they're not
God but Lucifer is jealous and he wants
to ascend himself above God he wants
people to think of him as God so he is
trying to show people that he is the
light
and in this world what is the light the
the symbol of light that we see the sun
so all these different names these
different gods looking at the sun
I'm gonna get to the point a little bit
later on but first
2 Corinthians 11 14 says and no wonder
for even Satan disguises himself as an
angel of Light now the sun has always
been used as the symbol of light
light and knowledge that is what the sun
was mostly used for so these gods are
all sun god allegories of Satan himself
came to give human beings knowledge
it started back with Adam and Eve in the
garden where he wanted them to eat of
the fruit so that they can get the
knowledge of evil
so the devil's plan was to bring the
knowledge of evil into the world through
Adam and Eve and that's what he did and
it is the same God that the Freemasons
still worship today just look at the one
dollar bill on the top of the pyramid at
the 33rd level of masonry those who
reach it who are deemed worthy receive
the final and biggest reward of
information
when you look at that pyramid picture
you see the sun there
all the 33 levels the sun illuminates it
shining its light and wisdom the
knowledge to them Illuminating all
all the sun allegories all of it points
to who
Satan now there is so much here that you
still need to find out and to to go and
research to learn yourself and then you
will realize how many politicians
corporations the banking system most of
the entertainment industry and even
power positions are part of this
and it stretches back to Nimrod who
wanted to control the world and back to
the anti-diluvian period
all of the strange things you've heard
like the secret societies of the Knights
Templar the Freemasons and all the
others it is just the tip of the iceberg
now I've just given you a little bit of
a summary in a little bit of history of
what could have happened and where we
are now where we are now
in his last 300 years is actually a lot
of information
but if you want to know more about this
then please let me know in the comment
section down below and I'll go into this
a little bit deeper this video has
already been too long and they say the
average attention span of a human today
is only 8.25 seconds so in part 7 of
this series
we're going further with the series of
10 life-changing truths every man must
know now what are we going to talk about
well we'll have to wait and see but I'm
gonna tell you this now as you've seen
it in all the other parts of this series
it's going to be a very interesting
video so subscribe if you don't want to
miss that video and remember
that life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys